اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
ساعه اخباريه مفصله نخصص معظمها لتطورات
المشهد السوداني بدايتها كالعاده بالعنوي
بعد موافقه طرفين نزاع في السودان على
تمديد الهدنه هدوء حذر يسود الخرطوم
الامم المتحده تحث طرفي الصراع في السودان
على حمايه المدنيين وتسهيل عمليات الاغاثه
وفي اخبارنا ايضا
اوكرانيا تعلن صده هجوم الروسي على كييف
واسقاط 15 صاروخا من اصل 18
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مع دخول الهدنه الجديده حيز
التنفيذ يسود هدوء حذر في الخرطوم فيما
نشر الجيش السوداني لقطات لقائد الجيش عبد
الفتاح البرهان وهو يشرف على سير العمليات
العسكريه من احد مراكز القياده
[موسيقى]
وكان الجيش السوداني وافق على تمديد
الهدنه لمده اثنتين وسبعين ساعه معلنا ان
الموقف العمليه مستقر في الخرطوم والوضع
هادئ في جميع الولايات وذلك بعد الموافقه
على تمديد الهدنه مع قوات الدعم السريع
لكن الجيش اضاف انه رصد تحركات للدعم
السريع من خارج العاصمه لتعزيز موقفه على
الارض مؤكدا جاهزيه الجيش لصد اي محاوله
للهجوم
السيطره كامله على كل الولايات 17
والسيطره
يعني بنسبه 80%
في ولايتي الخرطوم واما ولايه غرب
الكرتوفان غربي دارفور فهذه هي طبعا بها
متغير اللي هو متغير الاخير الذي تمثل في
اندلاع الصراع القبلي والذي يعني الان
يجري احتواءه بواسطه السلطات المحليه هناك
عن طريق لجنه امن الولايه وهذا المسلحه
يعني تسيطر تماما على جميع مقراتها بما
فيها القياده العامه بما فيها بيت الضيافه
وحتى منطقه القصر الجمهوري حديثهم يعني
وتركيزهم على السيطره على العاصمه ليست
ليس ليس صحيحا
قبل ذلك اعلنت قوات الدعم السريع الموافقه
على تمديد الهدنه الانسانيه لتنتين وسبعين
ساعه بما يسمح بفتح الممرات الانسانيه
وتسهيل حركه المواطنين والمقيمين وجددت
قوات الدعم السريع في بيان النشره على
صفحتها الرسميه على تويتر جددت التزامها
الذي وصفته بالصارم بالهدره الانسانيه
والوقف الكامل لاطلاق النار وقالت انها
تصدت لهجمات متكرره من الجيش خلال ايام
الهدنه
ووصلت قبل قليل سفينه حربيه امريكيه وصلت
الى ميناء جده الاسلامي من ميناء
بورتسودان وعلى متنها
318 اشخاص من سته عشره جنسي وكنا قد
تابعنا واياكم يوم امس من بورتسودان وصول
هذه السفينه الحربيه الامريكيه الى ميناء
بورتسودان وبعد ذلك
يعني اجلت من بورتسودان
380 اشخاص الى جده ومن جده ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه نصفيان هاني مرحبا بك معي
هاني ما التفاصيل لديك حول وصول هذه
السفينه الامريكيه والتي تقل اللاجئين
ايضا او رعايه امريكيه من السودان الى غرب
السعوديه
نعم
نعم اذا هذه الصور الاوليه التي الان
نلتقطها على شاشه العربيه وهي للسفينه
امريكيه تصل وتحمل على متنها
300 او اكثر من 300 شخص من سته عشر جنسيه
عموما سادعل الكاميرا تلتقط هذه الصور
بينما معاني القنصل الامريكي هنا في
السعوديه وهو الاستاذ فارس اسعد مرحبا بك
سامحني بس تعليق اصير اليوم لانه كتير
مشغولين كمان شايف احنا كلنا هون ولكن
مواطنين بس بحب اقول نحن كتير سعداء اليوم
انه رايحين نستقبل
مواطنينا من السودان احنا كتير متشكرين
للحكومه السعوديه ولا الشعب السعودي لكل
ساعدونا فيها لا هدع لحد الان
كما بتعرف انه من اعلى الاولويات لولايات
المتحده كما لكل الدول بالعالم اللي هي
امانه
مواط احنا كتير مبسوطين اليوم بدك تسامحني
عنك كتير شغل اليوم سته عشره جنسيه موجوده
هنا تحملونها ايضا على هذه
اكون حقيقه معك انا ما بعرف بالضبط كم ايش
عدد المواطنين الامريكيين ومن جنسيات اخرى
بس بقدر اقول لك انه في عدد من
من الاعداد الكبير بالضبط شكرا جزيلا
نعم سوف تكون هناك دفعه اخرى هل سفينه
اخرى سوف تلحقها بعد هذه السفينه سوف يكون
هناك لا هلا تعليقات على اي المعاملات
اللي احنا بنعمل فيها للامانه المواطنين
اللي ساعتهم بالسودان شكرا شكرا اذا كان
هذا حديث القنصل الامريكي في السودان
والذي تحدث ان هناك اعداد كبيره على متن
هذه السفينه برونز وهي اسم هذه السفينه
الحربيه وهي تعتبر من سفل سفن الانزال
التابعه للبحريه الامريكيه طبعا هذه
السفينه الامريكيه هي تعتبر اولى سفن
الامريكيه التي تصل سواء في ميناء جده
الاسلامي او كذلك الى الموانئ المحدده
والمواقع المحدده في السعوديه من اجل
اجراء الرعايه من جنسيات مختلفه هذه
السفينه تحديدا من اجمالي عدد السفن التي
وصلت الى السعوديه سواء التابعه للقوات
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه وكذلك من السفن
الاجنبيه والتجاريه هي تعتبر الرقم 26 هي
رقم 26 في
اسطول بحري سواء للسفن الاجنبيه التجاريه
او العسكريه او كذلك التابعه للقوات
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه طبعا بدا انزال
الجسر هنا لو نقوم باخذ هذه اللقطه بدا
انزال الجسر الرابط بين السفينه وكذلك
الرصيف
جدا لنزول
الاشخاص او الركاب على متن هذه السفينه
طبعا المعلومات الاوليه التي حصلت عليها
العربيه ان هذه السفينه تحمل على متنها
قرابه الثلاثمائه وثمانيه اشخاص من سته
عشره جنسيه حتى الان ولكن القنصل العام
الامريكي تحدث قبل قليل للعربيه
عن عن عن وجود لا يعلم بالضبط الرقم
الحقيقي عن الموجود على هذه السفينه او
حتى عدد جنسيات ولكن ما يعلمه ان مواطني
او هناك مواطنون من امريكا هم علامتنا هذه
السفينه وكذلك ايضا سالناه ما اذا كان
هناك سوف تتبعها عده سفن ورحلات سواء
اليوم او في الايام القادمه فقال من اجل
سلامه راينا هناك في السودان يجب ان لا
استطيع ان اعطيك
معلومات دقيقه وبدليل هذا ان هناك مازال
ايضا قد يكون العشرات او المئات من
الرعايه امريكا موجودون هناك في السودان
طبعا لا ننسى ان في الفتره الماضيه عبر
امريكا قامت باخلاق عمليه اجلاء لبعض
رعاياها عن طريق دول اوروبيه بعد اتفاقيات
ولكن كان اعدادهم بشكل بسيط وكان عن طريق
الطائرات كذلك الطائرات
الطائرات الاجنبيه ايضا في الفتره الماضيه
وعبر ايضا اسطول القوات البحريه الملكيه
السعوديه وايضا عبر بعض
الفرقاطات والقطاع البحريه العسكريه قامت
باجلاء عدد بسيطه جدا لا تتجاوز ال 10
اشخاص من رعايه امريكا الى جده وبعد ذلك
تم انهاء اجراءاتهم والتنسيق مع قنصرياتهم
وسفارتهم هنا ومغادرتهم
من جده الى امريكا طبعا ان ما زلنا نواكب
هذه اللحظه وهي تحديدا على رصيف رقم 46
الرصيف المخصص لوقوف هذه السفينه وهي كما
ذكرت هي سفينه انزال تقف لاول مره وتدخل
لاول مره من جده الاسلامي ونشاهد ايضا
الطابع العسكري سواء من على السفينه او من
هم ايضا على متن السفينه باستثناء الركاب
الموجودون هم يرتدون الزي العسكري على هذه
السفينه وهم طبعا البحريه الامريكيه كما
هو معروف انا لديها ايضا
خبره في عمليه الاجلاء وكذلك في عمليه
الانزال وكذلك في المواقع التي يستطيعون
التوجه او الوقوف بها داخل السودان
بالتنسيق سواء مع رعاياهم من الداخل او
التنسيق ايضا مع طرفي النزاع الموجودون
هناك في السودان طبعا هذه اللحظات ما زلنا
الان او بدا الجسر الخاص كما اوضحنا قبل
قليل بدا الجسر الخاص الرابط بين السفينه
السفينه يقوم
بربطه على الرصيف باستعدادا لنزول الركاب
والرعايه من 16 جنسيه وسوف تتضح المعلومات
ايضا اكثر وبشكل ادق ولكن هذه المعلومات
المؤكده التي وصلت للعربيه عن ان هناك
308 اشخاص من 16 جنسيه هم علامه هذه
السفينه هناك استعداد ايضا امني وايضا
عسكري من قبل
الجهات الامنيه السعوديه وايضا نتحدث عن
اكثر من 30 جهه حكوميه تشارك في عمليه
الاجلاء في سواء في الاسطول البحري في
الميناء او في قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
او ايضا لا ننسى ان هناك جسر جوي وفي هذه
اللحظات الان ونحن نتحدث في الجهه الاخرى
ولكن من قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه الان
تغادر بعد قليل سوف تغادر بعد قليل رحله
او طائره عسكريه هنديه سوف تتجه الى
السودان لنقل اعداد ايضا قد تكون قرابه
المئه واربعين شخص من رعايه الهند سوف
ياتون من السودان الى جده ولكن في هذه
اللحظات سوف تغادر الطائره العسكريه
الهنديه من قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه في مدينه جده باتجاه بورت سودان
طبعا استعداد عسكري وامني هنا حرس الحدود
السعودي والذي يشرف ايضا والمسؤول عن امن
ميناء جده الاسلامي هم يقفون صفا واحدا
استعدادا لنزول الرعايه وكذلك نشاهد
طبعا سوف هناك عدد الرحلات الاجمالي عدد
الرحلات التي وصلت عبر الاسطول
اسطول البحري 26 مع هذه السفينه سفينه
السفينه الامريكيه الان وصلت 26
سفينه عبر البحر سواء من قبل القوات
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه وهي 13 سفينه
ولدينا ايضا 13 سفينه عسكريه
اجنبيه وتجاريه وصلت الى ميناء جده
الاسلامي اي 26
سفينه باجمالي اعداد تجاوزت الخمسه الاف
شخص من جنسيات مختلفه ايضا هناك في الجسر
الجوي عدد الرحلات التي وصلت حتى الان الى
جده قرابه التسعه واربعين رحله بعدد رعايه
يتجاوزون الالفين واربعمائه شخص نحن نتحدث
عن
7000 نعم
الان يتم التعرف
بعض الكلمات الان التي قام فيها كابتن
كابتن السفينه ويقوم بالنزول واخذ الاذن
بانزال الركاب الان والسلام على القنصل
فارس اسعد القنصل الامريكي طبعا في
السعوديه وكذلك اللواء محمد الشهري
نائب
النائب مساعد قائد منطقه مكه المكرمه في
لحرس الحدود وكذلك
وحده الامن هنا العقيد عبد الله القحطاني
هم يتقابلون في
كلمات ترحيب للكابتن وكذلك القنصل
اذا سوف تبدا الان مرحله انزال الركاب بعد
اخذ الاذن النهائي وقمى عدد من الاعضاء
ومسوبيه السفاره كما نشاهد الامريكيه
بالصعود الى السفينه كي يتم الان بدء العد
الاجمالي والتاكد من العد الاجمالي
للرعايه الامريكيين او كذلك الجنسيات
الاخرى علامه السفينه تفضل نايف يعني انا
اشكرك جزيل الشكر على هذه المعلومات وربما
ايضا حتى التفاصيل الموسعه التي يعني
امديتنا بها من ميناء جده لوصول هذه
السفينه الحربيه الامريكيه التي تقل 318
اشخاص من 16 جنسيه وصلت الى جده قادمه من
بورتسودان شكرا جزيلا لك سنتابع مع كهاني
طبعا في سياق هذه النشره ونشرتنا ايضا
كذلك القادمه شكرا جزيلا لك مراسل العربيه
من جده نصفيان
اعلن برنامج الاغذيه العالميه عن استئناف
انشطته في السودان لتقديم المساعدات
العاجله في ظل تدهور الوضع الانساني في
البلاد ومن جهته قالت المديره التنفيذيه
للبرنامج على حسابها في تويتر ان الازمه
الحاليه في السودان تدفع الملايين الى
هاويه الجوع ما ادى لرفع التعليق المؤقت
لبرنامج الاغذيه العالمي في السودان هذا
وكان برنامج الاغذيه العالمي قد عطل عمله
في السودان بعد مقتل اعضاء من فريق
البرنامج جراء الاشتباكات بين قوات الدعم
السريعي والجيش
قال منسق لغاته الاممي في حالات الطوارئ
ان الجرافيس ان الوضع الانسانيه في
السودان وصل الى نقطه الانهيار بعد
اسبوعين من اندلاع الاشتباكات بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع واضاف جرافيكس في بيان
انه سيتوجه الى المنطقه لبحث الكيفيه التي
يمكن من خلالها تقديم اغاثه فوريه لملايين
الاشخاص الذين انقلبت حياتهم راسا على عقب
جراء الصراع في السودان بحسب البيان وذكر
ان عمليات النهب المكثفه للمكاتب
والمستودعات التابعه للامم المتحده ادت
الى نفادي معظم امداداتها في السودان
مشيرا الى ان المنظمه تبحث سبلا عاجله
لجلب وتوزيع امدادات اضافيه
اعلنت منظمه الصحه العالميه وقوع 26 هجوما
على مرافق رعايه الصحيه في السودان منذ
اندلاع الصراع بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع وقل المكتب الاقليمي للمنظمه في
شرق المتوسط على تويتر ان الهجمات على
مرافق الرعايه الصحيه تمثل انتهاكا صارخا
للقانون الدولي والحق في الحصول على
الرعايه الصحيه وشددت المنظمه على ضروره
توقف هذه الهجمات فورا
وقال الدكتور احمد المنظري المدير
الاقليمي لمنظمه الصحه العالميه ان هناك
ضعفا حقيقيا مخيفا جدا في النظام الصحي
بالسودان لاسيما نقص التمويل الطبي
والامدادات الطبيه بسبب انعدام الامن
وصعوبه الوصول الى المستشفيات
فعلا يعني نقص حقيقي في الكادر الطبي
وخصوصا بعد ظهور هذه الازمه خلال
الاسبوعين الماضيين يعني هناك نقص في
الكادر الطبي وخصوصا الكادر الطبي المتخصص
على سبيل المثال في الجراحه وفي التقدير
هناك نقص في التمويل
الطبي والامدادات الطبيه والمستلزمات
الطبيه خلال هذه الايام بسبب انعدام الامن
وصعوبه الوصول الى المستشفيات هناك نقص في
توفر بعد بعض المستلزمات الاساسيه على
سبيل المثال
الدم ومشتقاته هناك نقص في امدادات
الاكسجين هناك انقطاع متكرر للكهرباء
وكذلك يعني نقص في امدادات المياه نقص في
الوقود نقص في امدادات التغذيه للمرضى
والمقيمين في هذه المستشفيات
المنظر ياكد ان النظام الصحي في السودان
يعاني من هشاشه حقيقيه لافتا الى ان
العديده الى ان العديد من المنظمات
الرومانيه وغير الامميه تنسحب من السودان
بسبب الهجمات العسكريه المباشره عليها
هناك فرار للكثير من العقول العامله
والمدربه في النظام الصحي الى خارج
السودان كما يطلق عليه هجره عقول يعني
هناك في انسحاب لعدد من المنظمات الامميه
وغير الامميه بسبب الهجمات المباشره على
العاملين في هذه المنظمات فقدنا حتى الان
ما يقارب من 18 عامل في المنظمات
الانسانيه في السودان بسبب هذه الحرب
فلذلك يعني فعلا بسبب هذه الحرب النظام
الصحي في السودان تاثر تاثر كبير جدا جدا
جراء جراء هذا النزاع الحاصل
اعرب المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه في
السودان خالد عمر يوسف في مقابلته مع
العربيه عن ترحيبه باستجابه الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع للمبادره
السعوديه الامريكيه في تمديد الهدنه
لثلاثه ايام واشار خالد عمر الى ان الوضع
الانساني يتدهور بشكل ماساوي ومتسارع في
مناطق عديده من السودان وهو ما يتطلب
انجاح الهدنه ووقف اطلاق النار بشكل نهائي
نرحب باعلان كل من القوات المسلحه وقوات
السريع استجابتهم للمبادره الامريكيه
السعوديه
وتجديد الهدنه مره اخرى لثلاثه ايام على
الرغم من الهدن السابقه لم يتم الالتزام
بها بصوره كليه ولكن الهدنه المنتهيه
اليوم شهدت تحسن نسبي في الالتزام وهو
خطواتي للامام ان الوضع الانساني حقيقه
متدهور الان في مناطق عديده من السودان في
الخرطوم في دارفور في ولايات اخرى
تحدث معالجات في المستشفيات وفي محطات
المياه ومحطات الكهرباء فهنالك امن واسع
للغايه
جعل الناس مهددين في امنهم وهنالك حوادث
كثيره تحدث في المناظر مختلفه بالذات في
ولايه الخرطوم هذا الوضع يتدهور بصوره
متسارعه وهو ما يتطلب انجاح الهدنه اولا
الانتقال بها الى وقت دائم لاطلاق النار
ومن ثم يجعل حل سياسي
وحذر المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه خالد
عمر يوسف للعربيه من تحول الحرب في
السودان لطابع عرقي
من السهوله بمكانه التحول الحرب الموجوده
داخل ارض السودان الى حرد الطبيعه اقليميه
واردك لم يكن للسودانيين كلمه في ايقاف
هذه الحرب ايضا السودان محاط بمحيط هنالك
فيه نمو للعامال الارهابيه والجماعات
الارهابيه وبسهوله يستطيع ان يتحول الى
حاضنه لهذا الاعمال الارهابيه وانا ذاته
يستطيع احد السودانيين ايقاف ذلك يعني
وهذا الامر ستتجاوز اثاره حدود السودان
ولذلك اما ان ننقذ بلادنا الان من
الانهيار او بلادنا مرشحه تكون هي اسواك
كارثه انسانيه في العالم
من دنفر ينضم الينا خبير شور الافريقيه
ابراهيم ادريس سيد ابراهيم مرحبا بك معي
في هذه الساعه الهدنه اذا مددت للمره
السادسه في السودان بوساطه امريكيه سعوديه
برايك هل ستصمد هذه المره ام انها ستكون
تكرار وروتين لكل الهدن السابقه التي تم
اختراقها وبذات الهشاشه
اولا شكرا لاستضافه
عطفا على سؤالك حقيقه ما يتم الان من
مجهود السعوديه على مسارين المسار
الانساني
والمسار الدبلوماسي السياسي هم مساران لم
ياتان من فراق حيث السعوديه شاركت مع
الدول الخليج والمنظمات الدوليه
وايضا
الايجاد وجامعه الدول العربيه في في
اجتماع وزاري عالي
كانت دعت له
قياده الاتحاد الافريقي تحديدا السيد موسى
فكي مع الرئيس جزر الكمور الرئيس الدور
الاخيره للاتحاد الافريقي ماذا يعني هذا
يعني هذا انه هناك تنسيق مشترك بين كل هذه
الاطراف لاسيما مصر والسعوديه وامريكا على
مرحلتين المرحله الاولى كثافه مصريه
سعوديه في الاتصالات بعد الاتصالات
المصريه في جنوب السودان التي عقبتها
الايجاد كل هذه المستويات التي تتحرك في
مسار واحد وليس مسارات متعدده وباتفاق
مشترك الان ايضا ياتي
بدعوه من سكرتير العام بعد ان وضحت الصوره
من التقرير الذي قدمه مندوب
الاون المتحده في اجتماع مجلس مجلس الامن
الاخير مع الاستاذه السيده السفينه فاطمه
محمد عن الاتحاد الافريقي كل هذه المعطيات
مشتركه دفعت بان الموقف السعودي يتميز في
هذه المرحله حيث انه لقاء السيد دفع الله
الحاج
سفير السودان سابقه في الاون متحده ومدير
عام القضايا الدوليه في وزاره الخارجيه
سابقا شخصيه
امكانات في العلاقات الدوليه يتم الرساله
للرياض هذه ايجابيات مكثفه وبالتالي هل
يمكن البناء على كل ما ذكرته الان استاذ
ابراهيم بان تصمد هذه الهدنه بان يكون
سيناريو مختلف عن الهدن السابقه لا يتم
اختراقها ان يتم البناء على ما بعد الهدنه
ايضا كذلك
لمحاوله بناء ثقه بين طرفي هذه الازمه
الجلوس على طاوله الحوار او الانفتاح على
الاقل على هذه
على هذه الطاوله والجلوس عليها ايضا كما
ذكر بولكر بيريتس يوم امس وكذلك مع قدوم
ايضا السيد مارتن جرافيتس الى السودان
سؤالك الصب في في عظم زي ما يقولوا الازمه
حيث فشل
الهدنات الخمسه
وبروزه الان الهدنه السادسه استوعبت
القيادات السياسيه والدبلوماسيه
والاقليميه خطوره الانفلات
الانفلات التي ياتي من اتهام الطرفان
لبعضهما هنا راينا في هذه التحركات
السعوديه هناك ثلاثه محاور سيقيف عليها
هذا المرحله الاولى من التفاوض واهمها هو
تحديد اليات المراقبه يعني بذلك انه
سيتدخل جهات فنيه ذات الطبيعه امنيه
وعسكريه في انها تراقب من المجتمع الدولي
هذه الهدنه وما تستمر عليه ما يعزز هذا
الموقف وصول المرتقب لمارت ليس هو فقط
وكيل الامين العام للشؤون الان هو خلفيه
سياسيه
مستوعبه كل هذه القضايا راينا في الاخيره
في اليمن وما بذلهم بمجهود عليه اتوقع انه
يكون هناك تامين لاليات المراقبه قضيه
اساسيه يجب ان يجاوب عليها نفود القادمه
الى السعوديه من الاطراف المتصارعه ونعمل
ان نرى يعني ركائز موضوعيه لضمان اداريه
للهدنه السادسه اشكرك جزيلا الشكر من دون
فرع عاصمه ولايه كولورادو الامريكيه خبير
الشون الافريقيه ابراهيم ادريس شكرا جزيلا
لك
يواجهه الكثير من السودانيين مصاعب حقيقيه
في ممارسه حياتهم اليوميه بسبب الاقتتال
الدائري في بلادهم وتاثيرهم على حياه
السكان بشكل مباشر حيث لجا الاهالي واصحاب
المحلات التجاريه في سوق الرابعه في ام
درمان بولايه الخرطوم الى المشي سيرا على
الاقدام للتسوق مع غياب وسائل المواصلات
بسبب عدم توفر الوقود وارتفاع الاسعار كما
يعاني عمال السباكه والكهرباء وحرف اخرى
من عدم توفر فرص العمل بسبب الحرب
فتره الطول الحرب بنيه شغل لكن معاناته
والله بامانه كده يعني حكايه ظرف صعب جدا
العمل متوقف
الطين بله
وقف الرسم
قادر اشيل شيل بسيط اهو
لكن هنا ما في شي
المواصلات
عشان تجي السوق ده وترجع السوق من القريب
ده بالنسبه لمحل انا
قاعد في بيتي
في بورتسودان رصد مراسل العربيه نزار
بقداوي احوال العالقين الذين ينتظرون
الخروج من البلاد نشاهد
نحو اليوم العاشر تمضي عمليات الاجلاء
لرعايه دول العربيه والاجنبيه والاسيويه
من شرق السودان الى عدد من الدول في
المنطقه اكثر من نحو عشره الاف من رعايه
الدول الاجنبيه تم اجلائهم خلال الايام
القليله الماضيه عبر ميناء بورتسودان وما
يقدر لاكثر من سته الاف غادروا عبر مطار
بورسودان الدولي الى وجهات دوليه مختلفه
ومع استمرار عمليات الاجلاء الا ان مئات
من الاسر السوريه واليمنيه ما تزال حتى
اليوم في انتظار استكمال اجراءات مغادرتها
للبلاد احنا مو طالبين اكثر من نوع يتم
اجلان احنا مطالبين من اي بلد يقعدوا في
الناس او يستضيفهم شكرا احنا بس بدنا ممر
امن من هنا الى الحدود السوريه وشكرا
البعض تفضل البقاء داخل مركز التسجيل
والحصر هنا واخرون عملت السلطات المحليه
على توفير دور مؤقته لايوائهم في ظل ظروف
يحاول الجهد الرسمي والشعبي بمدينه
بورسودان تخفيف وطاتها على العائلات
والنساء والاطفال الموجودين حاليا بشرق
السودان نزار البداوي لقنات العربيه
والحدث مدينه بورسودان الشرقيه السودان
ويصل الاف سودانيين الفرين الى الحدود
المصريه عن طريق منفذ قسطل البري لتكون
مدينه ابو سمبل اولى محطات استقبالهم هل
المدينه حرسوا على تقديم كافه انواع
المساعده للنازحين الهاربين من الاشتباكات
الداميه في بلادهم
والله انا يعني سم ده وانا
بقينا الكرم ولقينا الضيافه ولقينا منهم
والله كل خير يعني وجبنا
اللبن للاطفال وببرونها للاطفال
وبامبرز للاطفال جبناهم مستشفى ابو سمبل
يعمل على قدم الوثائق لاستقبال النازحين
موفرين لهم ما يحتاجونه من دواء واسعافات
من كل الهيئات الصحيه سواء تامين شامل
سواء وزاره الصحه حتى برضو لقينا برضو
مساعدات من جهات تانيه ففضل الله محدش
مقصر يعني
ورغم اصراري اغلب من ياتون الى ابو سمبل
لاستكمال رحلاتهم لمدينه اسوان فان
مستقبليهم يصرون على دعوتهم للمبيت في
بيوتهم للراحه من وعثاء السفر الطويل سكان
ابو سمبل يؤكدون دائما بان السودان يمثل
لهم امتدادا ليس جغرافيا فقط ولكن انسانيا
ايضا كلمات وشعارات برهنت الاحداث على مدى
مصداقيتها احمد عثمان العربيه من مدينه
ابو سمبل محافظه اسوان
ومن القاهره نرحب بالكاتب الصحفي المختصه
في القضايا الاقليميه هند الضاوي ومن
الخرطوم ايضا ارحب برئيس تحرير صحيفه
التيار عثمان مرغني مرحبا بكم معي في هذه
الساعه وابدا معك سيد عثمان
للسؤال عن دلالات نشر هذه الصور لقائد
الجيش
الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان في ظل هذه
الهدنه التي مددت للمره السادسه وعلى وقع
الاشتباكات التي حدثت يعني يوم امس في
اكثر من منطقه ومفصل حيوي مهم في العاصمه
الخرطوم الذي تعني
واستخدام الصور بالتحديد في الاعلام
لارسال رسائل
لعده اتجاهات
اولها للجنود التي يعملون في القوات
المسلحه السودانيه هو رفع اللوحه المعنويه
وثانيها للشعب السوداني الذي يتابع اخبار
الحرب الان ان تنتهي في اعجل ما تيسر
ويساند الجيش السوداني بصوره كبيره
والثالثه طبعا للطرف الاخر وهو قوات بان
الجيش وقياده الجيش متماسكه هو ان
الحرب لدى قياده الجيش طويل وان الطرف
الاخر فقط هو الذي قد يستهلك او يستنفذ
جهده دون ان يحقق الاهداف التي يريدها هذا
من زاويه طبعا الزاويه اعلاميه وتتعلق
وجزء من الحرب النفسيه المستخدمه الهدى
التي اعلنت حتى الان وهي يعني مخترقه كلها
تساهمت في الوصول الى مرحله
في وقف اطلاق النار وقبول للطرفين بهذا
المقترح رغم انه لم يبدا تنفيذه على الارض
ولم تبدا الحوارات دوله التفاوض بين
الطرفين لكن مؤشر واضح جدا ان الهدن
وساهمت
الدفع الطرفين نحو الحوار والتفسير في
الطاقه النار وهي خطوه متقدمه يمكن ان
تساهم في الحرب كخطوه اولى بعد بعدها يمكن
الاتجاه نحو التفاوض المباشر بالاسباب
التي ادت للحرب ويمكن بعد ذلك الوصول
لمرحله الاستقرار والسلام السيده هند يعني
هناك مساله ربما طرح كثيرا السؤال عليها
علامات الاستفهام ايضا في ظل يعني تصاعد
هذه الاشتباكات في الخرطوم تحديدا في عدد
ايضا من
المدن او الولايات القريبه كذلك من
الخرطوم هناك موجه نزوح داخليه وكذلك ايضا
خارجيه الى حدود الدول المجاوره للسودان
هل هناك ما يق لق هذه الدول المجاوره
للسودان من موجات النزوح الكبيره باتجاه
حدودها
بعد التحيه اللي حضرتك واللي سيد عثمان
وللمشاهدين بالطبع هناك قلق شديد يساوي
الدول السبع المحيطه بالسودان نظرا
لارتداد او يعني تبعات وتداعيات الحرب على
هذه الدول ومنها ملف النازحين في وضع
اقتصادي متدهور على مستوى العالم في عدم
استقرار نسبي يضرب هذه الدول ويضرب
افريقيا بشكل عام في ظل سيناريوهات قديمه
في بدايه يعني عام 2011 حيث يعني كان هناك
فوضى او ما يطلق عليه الفوضى الخلاقه في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط لعبت فيه الحدود دور
هام في تفكيك يعني بعض الدول من الداخل
ومنها كانت مصر تعرضت لنفس السيناريو
ولعبه الحدود السودانيه وقطاع غزه دور
كبير في نشر الفوضى في الداخل المصري
وبالتالي المسؤوليه كبيره الان على دول
الجوار مصر لها خصوصيه في التعامل نظرا
لانها ترى او النظره اليقينيه في مصر ان
ما يحدث في السودان يستهد كما يستهدف
السودان هي تشدد الرقابه بشكل كبير على
الحدود يعني استقبلت حتى الان اكثر من
خمسه عشر الف نازح من الاشقاء السودانيين
تنخرط في العمليه السياسيه ولكن هي تريد
ايقاف الحرب عند هذا الحد لان السودان عدد
سكانه كبير جدا مصر لها افضليه بالنسبه
للمواطن السوداني نظرا لما تتمتع به من
استقرار امن كبير واستقرار اقتصادي نسبي
وبالتالي هي جهه مفضله لم يعني لا يوجد
خلافات حقيقيه ما بين الشعب المصري والشعب
السوداني ربما نجد ذلك ما بين الشعب
السوداني وبعض الدول الافريقيه الحدوديه
وبالتالي التداعيات كبيره وخطيره الكل
يحاول ان يصل الى تهدئه في السودان حتى
يمنع سيناريو الفوضى وانتشار الحركات
الراديكاليه ويعني موجات الهجره الغير
شرعيه باستثناء او بعيدا عن حتى النازحين
يعني في اقرب وقت لان السيناريوهات
الموضوعه من القوى الكبرى لهذه المنطقه
ربما تعصف بكثير من الدول الافريقيه
والعربيه في حال استمر الصراع على ان في
النهايه السودان لديه محيطين محيط افريقيا
ومحيط عربي كلا منهم يتاثر بالداخل
السوداني اذا استمرت الحرب لا قدر الله
يعني لن تتوقف او لن تنحصر ما بين
العسكريين ولكن سيكون لها يعني امتداد
قبلي لان الديموغرافيه تلعب دور في الداخل
السوداني كل هذه السيناريوهات يعني السيئه
مطروحه ويبقى الامل على تهدئه شامله في
اقرب وقت ممكن يعني استاذ عثمان
ماذا بعد تمديد هذه الهدنه برايك للمره
السادسه
نعم يعني هذه هي الهدنه السادسه
يومها السابع
عشر ها 14 يوم هدى هي الحرب الحقيقيه من
غير الهدنه هي ثلاثه ايام فقط هذا يعني
عمليه هد
نه لكنها فقط استخدمت اللي علاقات عامه
بالنسبه للطرفين وقبول
وقبول مثل هذه المبادرات في الزاويه
الايجابيه هي ساهمت في حوار الذي يقضي
لوقف اطلاق النار الدائم هذه تحتاجه
المفاوضات وافقت الطرفان عليها في هذه
وشرعان الشرعان في تحديد المناديق ولكل
منهما ثم
بعد زادت العم
ليه في مكان ما غالبا مدينه جده العربيه
السعوديه وتبدا مباحثات انا اتوقع ان لا
تستغرق وقت ستكون سريعه في الوصول الى وقف
اط
لاق الدولي او اقليميه هذه المرحله ستكون
حاسمه ويمكن ان تكون هي المخرج الذي يؤدي
الى الاتفاق النهائي السياسيه تسمح بانهاء
الحرب بصوره كامله دعوه الامم المتحده
لحمايه المدنيين لتسهيل ايضا كذلك عمليه
دخول
الاغاثه كذلك للسودان كيف سيتم التفاعل
معها من قبل طرفي الازمه ومن يملك يعني
اوراق ضغط على طرفي هذه الازمه لتسهيل عمل
الامم المتحده والمنظمات الاغاثيه لما
يعانيه السودان اليوم من وضع الانساني صعب
في البدايه يعني فكره دخول المساعدات
الانسانيه يعني اجلاء المرضى والمصابين
هذا الامر سيتوقف على طريقه تعامل طرفي
النزاع مع التاكيد ان عنصر الانضباط غير
متوافر في الميدان السوداني حتى الان يعني
هناك تجاوب من طرفي النزاع مع المجتمع
الدولي لان الصراع في بدايته وكل طرف
يحاول ان يكتسب اكبر قدر ممكن من الدعم
الاقليمي والدولي هذا الامر اعتقد انه في
حال استمرار الحرب لن يستمر لفتره طويله
هناك عنصر غير نظامي في هذا الصراع وهو
عنصر قوات الدعم السريع وشاهدنا عمليات
يعني النصب والسرقه والاحتلال والاعتداءات
على المنازل وبالتالي ليس او لا يوجد جهه
حقيقيه تستطيع يعني القاء التهم عليها
وتحملها مسؤوليه ما يحدث يعني الامل هو
بالنسبه للامم المتحده ام بالفعل بالتوازي
مع العمليات الانسانيه يكون هناك بالفعل
اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار هناك بعض وسائل
الاعلام السودانيه تتحدث منذ مساء امس بان
بالفعل المبادره الامريكيه السعوديه حققت
اختراق حقيقي وان كان هناك مفاوضات غير
مباشره استمرت لايام حتى الاحد يعني امس
وتوصلوا لتفاوض مباشر الثلاثاء القادم
يتضمن اربع خطوات اولا هدنه انسانيه وقف
دائم لاطلاق النار تفاوض ما بين العسكريين
حل شامل للازمه السودانيه اذا تحقق ذلك
بالفعل ووصلنا الاهم ان نصل للحل الشامل
لان اي حلول في السودان دون التوصل لحمل
لشامل ينقل الحكم للمدنيين سيظل الصراع ما
بين العسكريين في السودان وكما ذكرت سيكون
له احتمالات او تداعيات خطيره على الداخل
السوداني وعلى محيطيه العربي والاقليمي
الامم المتحده في النهايه تسعى عبر
ادواتها وعبر الدول الكبرى وحتى الدول
الاقليميه التي لديها علاقات قويه معها
ولكن في النهايه الاداء الملزمه
لم يتبقى لدي الكثير من الوقت من القاهره
كاتبه صح فيه المختصه بالقضايا الاقليميه
عند الضاوي وامن العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم رئيس تحرير صحيفه التيار عثمان
مرغني شكرا جزيلا لكم
ارتفع عدد الاشخاص الذين
اجلاهم الاردن من السودان الى 661 شخصا
بينهم 469 اردنيا ومائه 192 من رعايه
اجانب وعرب واعلنت وزاره الخارجيه
الاردنيه ان طائره تابعه للجيش الاردني
نقلت من عمان الى مطار بورتسودان مساعدات
طبيه وانسانيه وحملت الطائره مساعدات
قدرت بثمانيه اطنان من المساعدات للصليب
الاحمر في السودان
اول بدايه
واثنين ثلاثه هنا
في قسم شرطه قعدنا محل الجسم توالي دلو
الليله حرب جاي وبلومه دقيت لعيال التلفون
قلت
لهنا طوالي اتحركنا من هنا ومشينا
[موسيقى]
الان وقفه لابرز الاخبار الدوليه اذا
بعدها ان دعم مسؤول اوكراني المدنيين الى
البقاء في الملاجئ مع اطلاق السفارات
الانذار لنحو ثلاث ساعات من ساعه الصباح
الاولى اكد القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
ان دفاعاتهم اسقطت 15 صاروخ الروسيا من
اصل 18 موضحا ان كل الصواريخ الروسيه التي
حاولت استهداف كيف تم التصدي لها ولا
اصابات وقعت اثرها حسب المعلومات الاوليه
كما افادت ايضا وسائل اعلام اوكرانيه
افادت عن وقوع انفجارات اخرى في دنيبرو
بتروفيسكو ومناطق فيسومي
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه افادت لوكاله
الروسيه ان قوات بلاده استهدفت في وقت
مبكر من صباح اليوم عده مواقع لمدفعيه
الجيش الاوكراني في دونتسك واكد المتحدث
باسم الدفاع الروسيه للوكاله ان القوات
الروسيه قامت بشن غارات ناريه على ثلاثه
مواقع لمدفعيه الجيش الاوكراني مضيفا ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تكبدت خسائر بشريه وصلت
الى 60 شخصا
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قوتها
استولت على اربع مناطق في غرب مدينه وتاتي
تصريحات الدفاع الروسيه مع تواصل المعارك
في باخمه ومحاولات الجيش الروسي للسيطره
على المدينه التي تعتبرها روسيا مفصلا
مهما في تغيير مسار المعارك في اوكرانيا
ومن كيف ينضم الينا الصحفيه محمد البابا
محمد مرحبا بك معي في هذه النشره يعني
القوات الروسيه كانت قد شنت هجوم على
مواقع للجيش الاوكراني في دونتسك ربما
ايضا شاهدنا صور على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي
لفوهات كبيره من النار في هذه المناطق
الشرقيه في اوكرانيا كيف هو الوضع ما الذي
حدث في ساعات الليل والصباح ايضا
نعم بالفعل يعني منذ مسائل امس شن القوات
الروسيه ضربات مدفعيه على طول خط التماس
المدفعيه يعني الصواريخ الروسيه من نوع اس
3 مئات استهدفت مناطق بالقرب من سلافياس
ماريانكا
وحاولت القوات الروسيه التقدم يعني التقدم
في داخل مدينه باخمد الا انها واجهت
الدفاع من القوات الاوكرانيه هناك
اشتباكات عنيفه جدا للجيش الاوكراني يستمر
بارسال التعزيزات الى يعني المنطقه
الغربيه التي لا تزال تحت السيطره القوات
الاوكرانيه في مدينه في ايضا الجيش
الاوكراني شنه هجوم لابعاد المدفعيه
الروسيه وتراجع القوات الروسيه 6
كيلومترات عند اطراف مدينه او بالقرب من
مدينه اكزييفكا ماريانكا هناك ايضا
اشتباكات كبيره تحاول قوات الروسيه الدخول
والسيطره على تلك المدينه وايضا تواجه
يعني دفاع كبير للقوات الاوكرانيه بينما
الوضع في كل اوكرانيا بالامس عند الساعه
الثالثه صباحا دوت سفارات الانذار في كامل
الاراضي الاوكرانيه بعدما اطلقت روسيا عبر
طائرات طو 95 ثمانيه عشر صاروخ كروس
باتجاه الاراضي الاوكرانيه وبحسب الدفاع
يعني وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه استطاعت
الدفاعات الجويه اسقاط خمسه عشر صاروخا
بينما ثلاثه صواريخ سقطوا على منطقه شعبيه
او حي شعبي داخل
مما ادى الى تدمير منازل 16 منزل تضرر بعد
سقوط هذه الصواريخ ايضا مدينه سومي تعرضت
لصواريخ اس 300 اطلقت من الاراضي الروسيه
سكتت عند اطراف مدينه سومي يعني في
ضواحيها ولكن دون وقوع اصابات الدفاعات
الجويه ايضا يعني وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
اكدت ان الدفاعات الجويه خلال الهجومين
السابقين على العاصمه الاوكرانيه استطاعت
اسقاط جميع الصواريخ التي تم اطلاقها على
العاصمه الاوكرانيه يعني قبل يومين يوم
الجمعه كان ليله الجمعه كان هناك احد عشر
صاروخ في محيط العاص الاوكرانيه هي تم
اسقاطه وبالامس بالامس ليله الامس ثمانيه
صواريخ وفي ساعات الصباح الاولى ثمانيه
صواريخ التروس اسقطت في محيط العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف ما يعني ان الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه اصبحت تدافع بشكل كبير
وتحمي سماء العاصمه الاوكرانيه من اي
ضربات صاروخيه خاصه يعني خلال الفتره
الماضيه كانت الدفاعات الجويه تتكثف
واوكرانيا حصلت على منظومات باتيريوت
ومنظومات من سامسونج الامريكيه الصنع ومن
كندا ايضا هناك منظومات وصلت الى اوكرانيا
ساهمت في حمايه السماء الاوكرانيه وخاصه
في وسط اوكرانيا والعصر ماذا عن الهجوم
المضاد
والهجوم المتوقع في
الربيع كذلك محمد
وما يتداول داخل وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
والراي العام الاوكراني انها ايام قليله
تفصلنا عن بدء الهجوم المضاد الذي تعد له
زمن الدفاع الاوكرانيه لاستعاده الاراضي
التي تم
اكثر من منظومه حمايه العاصمه الاوكرانيه
وايضا وصل عدد كبير من الجنود الذين تلقوا
تدريبات خلال الفتره خلال الاشهر الثلاثه
والاربع الماضيه وصلوا الى اوكرانيا
وانخرطوا في الجبهات والان يعني هناك حشر
كبير للقوات الاوكرانيه استعدادا للهجوم
المضاد بحسب ما يتداول هناك اكثر من 250
الف جندي اوكرانيا اصبحوا جاهزين لبدء
الهجوم المضاد ولكن ينتظرون ساعه الصفر
حتى هذه اللحظه لا معلومات عن موعد ومكان
وكيفيه الهجوم المضاد ولكن جميع القاده
العسكريين يقولون ان الاستعدادات
اللوجستيه اصبحت في خطواتها الاخيره
الاستعدادات الميدانيه تم الانتهاء منها
والان وضع الخطط يعني بيد وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه والرئيس الاوكراني الذي سيعطي
الامر
على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل من كيف
الصحه في محمد الباب
في اتصال هاتفي كرر الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل
ماكرون لنظيره الاوكراني فلودي التزامه
تقديم كل المساعدات الضروريه الى اوكرانيا
لتستعيد سيادتها ووحده اراضيها وفق ما
افاد الاليزي وقالت الرئاسه الفرنسيه
انماكرون تناول مع زيلينسكي التنسيق
الاوروبي والدعم العسكري لتلبيه احتياجات
اوكرانيا على المدى البعيد
في فرنسا تستعد النقابات لاحياء يوم
تاريخي لعيد العمال اذ تتوقعوا نزول ما
يصل الى مليون ونصف المليون شخص الى
الشوارع لمواصله الاحتجاج على اصلاح نظام
التقاعد الذي اقره الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرون
وقال الامير العام للاتحاد الديمقراطي
الفرنسي للعمل انهم يتوقعون مشاركه مئات
الالاف من المتظاهرين موضحا ان النقابات
اعدت 300 نقطه تجمع في مختلف انحاء البلاد
لاحياء عيد الاول من مايو من جهتها تتوقع
السلطات نزول نحو 650 الف متظاهر من ضمنهم
ما بين 80 الى 100 الف في باريس وحدها كما
اكدت ان اثني عشر الف عنصر من الشرطه
والدركسين لضمان الامن
قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
ماثيو ميلر في بيان ان وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انطوني بلينكن اعرب في اتصاله
مع رئيس الاذربيجاني الهام علياف ان قلق
الولايات المتحده العميق من ان يؤدي انشاء
اذربيجان لنقطه تفتيش على ممر لاتشين الى
تقويض جهود بناء الثقه في عمليه السلام
وممر لاتشين مشاهدينا هو الرابط البري
الوحيد بين ارمينيا ومنطقه ناغورني وقد
اقامت اذربيجان نقطه التفتيش نهايه
الاسبوع الماضي في خطوه اعتبرتها ارمينيا
خرقا لوقف اطلاق النار الاخير المعلن بين
الجانبين اضاف البيان ان بلينكن شدد على
اهميه اعاده فتح ممر لاتشين امام المركبات
التجاريه والخاصه في اقرب وقت ممكن واكد
على اهميه محادثات السلام بين ارمينيا
وتعهد بمواصله الولايات المتحده دعمها
لتلك المحادثات
اعلن الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان مقتل
الزعيم المفترض لتنظيم داعش في سوريا خلال
عمليه نفذتها لاستخبارات التركيه
ان بلاده ستواصل عملها في محاربه
التنظيمات الارهابيه دون استثناء
اود ان اشارك الجمهور معلومات جديده خلال
هذا اللقاء هناك التطور يظهر معركه نصار
مضاد التنظيمات الارهابيه الاستخبارات
التركيه كانت تتعقب منذ زمن طويل من يسمى
زعيم داعش المعروف بابو حسين القرشي وهذه
هي المره الاولى التي اعلن فيها هذا الخبر
خبر القضاء على هذا الشخص خلال عمليه
نفذها جهاز الاستخبارات التركي في سوريا
وسنواصل عملنا لمحاربه المنظمات الارهابيه
دون استثناء
تجمع عشرات الالاف الاتراك في الساحات
العامه في تجمعات الانتخابيه قبل
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والتشريعيه منتصف
مايو وجمع كل من الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
ومنافسه ايضا الابرز كمال كلش دار اوغلو
حشودا ضخمه وتوعد كل منهما الاخر بالهزيمه
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
حشد وحشد المقابل في تركيا قبل اسبوعين
على الرابع عشر من مايو الذي ربما يكون
موعد الحسم في الانتخابات الرئاسيه الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان كان استانف السبت حملته
الانتخابيه ونشاطه العامه بعد وعكه صحيه
المت به الاسبوع الماضي حتى في انقره
مواطنيه ممن لم يحسموا خيارهم بعد على
التصويت لصالحه كما توعد اردوغان مرشح
المعارضه وقال امام الالاف من مؤيديه في
العاصمه ان الشعب التركيه سيخرج مرشح
المعارضه من الحياه السياسيه وعدد لسكان
انقره ما قال انها انجازاته انقر باتت
عاصمه للصناعات الدفاعيه بفضل الاستثمارات
الحكوميه خلال العقدين الماضيين عملنا على
تطوير وتنميه انقره ورفع مستوى الرفاهيه
فيها على مدى عقدين شانها شان كفته مدن
تركيا الاخرى
غرب البلاد وفي مدينه ازمير معقل المعارضه
شدد زعيم ومرشح المعارضه كمال اوغلو على
ان الانتخابات خطوه على طريق اعاده بناء
الديمقراطيه التركيه متعهدا باعاده
الاستقرار للبلاد باصواتكم سنخرج تركيا من
هذا الوضع في عهد لن يكون هناك تمييز
ساحتضن 85 مليون تركي سواء صوتوا لي ام لا
يمكن للجميع التاكد من ان كمال سيكون الى
جانبكم جميعا
واردوغان يؤكدان على امكانيه الفوز من
الدوره الاولى الا ان التوقعات تشير الى
ترجيح حسم اسم الرئيس عبر دوره اقتراع
ثانيه تقام في 28 من مايو حسن جوليد
العربيه
سخر الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن من
الانتقادات التي وجهت اليه بسبب اعاده
ترشحه في الثمانين من عمره وقال بايدن
خلال حفل عشاء مراسله البيت الابيض ان
كتابه دستور الامريكي صديقه
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن وكانه في هذا
المشهد يخرج من فيلم سينمائي
[تصفيق]
تشق الضحكه فمه وتاره ترسم الابتسامه على
شفاه الجمهور خلال حفل عشاء مراسلي البيت
الابيض بواشنطن استغله بايدن ليتحدث عن
انجازاته خلال فتره ولايته ليتطرق عقبها
الى تعليق ساخر عن طرد المذيع الشهير
تاكلس من شبكه فوكس نيوز الاخباريه فمن دق
الباب اسمعه بايدن الجواب بفكاهته
[تصفيق]
لدينا الكثير لنفخر به نشرنا اللقاح
اصلحنا الاقتصاد وانتصرنا في الانتخابات
النصفيه ولم ينتهي العمل بعد لكنه انتهى
بالنسبه
فتنضرب فيها عصفورين بحجر واحد ففي تكمله
خطابه الذي يبدو وكانه منصه لعرض كوميدي
المح الى اهانه نيكي هيلي المرشحه
الجمهوريه للرئاسه التي عايرته براسه الذي
اشتعل شيبا فعدى عن وصفها اياه بانه اضعف
رئيس في التاريخ الحديث قالت انه قد لا
يعيش لولايه ثانيه
بعبيد النكاته ويصف رابع رئيس للولايات
المتحده بصديقه الصدوق جيمس ماديسن الملقب
بابي الدستور ومنشئ الحزب الجمهوري
بعد كل ذلك انا اؤمن بالتعديل الاول ليس
فقط لان صديقي العزيز جيمس ماديسون كتبه
اصدق القول ربما فلا تتوا الدعابه
المدروسه تلك ففي حفل العشاء هذا لم يترك
بايدن احدا وشانه للملياردير الامريكي
ايلون ماسك وللرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
ولا حاكم ولايه فلوريدا والكثير غيرهم اهم
من هذا كله وقف ليقول كلمته 80 ولكن في
اوج عطائي
[موسيقى]
اسراء الصغيره العربيه
وثقت مقاطع فيديو مشاهد للاعصار الذي ضرب
ولايه فلوريدا الامريكيه وتسبب بانقطاع
كهربائي عن حوالي 4000 شخص وكان من اكثر
المقاطع نفته للانتباه ما نقله شهود عيان
قالوا ان احدى المركبات انقلبت وتحطمت على
الرصيف وتطاير ركامها امامهم
نهايه هذه الساعه الاخباريه التي تناولنا
في معظمها الملف السوداني تغطيه الاخبار
في السودان مستمره مشاهدينا على راس
الساعه مع الزميله ليال الاختيار
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات